So before I start today's class I'd like to take you on a trip that I recently
did to share some of the things that excite me in my life with all of you.
I actually went to Washington, D.C. and the highlight of the day for
me was to visit the National Museum of American History.
Some of you might know this.
In 1998 a team led by Wolfram Burgard and
myself put a robotic tour guide into this museum.
This robot was in the museum for about two weeks and it led kids and
visitors of the museum through the exhibit.
It did localization similar to what I taught you before.
It used a learned map of the environment.
We programmed by hand the specific location of exhibits and
was also able to say something.
It was also able to smile and to frown.
And as you can see in this video, sometimes even kids climbed onto it.
But today I'm here to see Stanley.
Stanley has been here for a couple of years now in exhibits our robot that won
the DARPA Grand Challenge, and it was really fascinating to see the thing
that we've built and visited in its own little room in the Smithsonian museum.
This exhibit has been made specifically to celebrate Stanley's victory.
And in exploring this exhibit again I found that the curators had
actually put some program code on the wall for people to understand.
Let's zoom in.
You can see Kalman.
So, at the time you are already working with Kalman filters and
in our parameter file, as shown here, the word Kalman occurs many times.
So, what I've been teaching you last class about the Kalman filter really had
a major role to play in making Stanley the robot win the DARPA Grand Challenge.
So these are deep emotional moments for me going back to the past and
seeing what we've done and how it's been preserved.
But I want to share with everybody here because it’s part of my life and
it’s part of what we’ve done in building self-driving cars, and
the methods I’m teaching you in this class are essentially the same methods as
we used back in Stanley and in Junior when we did the Urban Challenge.